happy friday everybody beautiful shot as
we look out over
red rock in the spring mountains red
rocks 58 degrees right now a little bit
of a southwest breeze
and they're having spring fun up at lee
canyon but look for the winds up there
through the spring mountains this
weekend temperatures will be in the 50s
at lee canyon
and 60s for kyle canyon right now 41
degrees up there
we've got mostly 60s around the valleys
we take a tour around centennial hills a
little cooler at 58
aliante at 64. some 50s at nellis right
now downtown at 65.
low 60s out on the east side at sunrise
mountain 63 in henderson
seven hills a little cooler 257 61 on
the strip
so here are your headlines we've got
warm 80s coming for the next couple of
days and then a very windy weekend even
saturday's looking very windy
into sunday where we get clouds coming
in sunday ahead of a pretty strong
pacific storm that's going to be much
cooler
snow in those mountains this by monday
and the chance of valley rain we need it
desperately we really do
highs will drop to the cooler 60s for a
day on monday and then we'll
heat up again next week showers and
thunderstorms
through the mid-south in the deep south
today the upper midwest
still a little bit of snow for the
rockies and we've got this strong system
out here in the pacific that's really
starting to take shape winds tomorrow 30
to 40 miles an hour and then very low
humidity
fire weather watches have already been
issued for saturday that's all of clark
county
mohave county arizona 11 a.m to 8 p.m
please
please watch out for anything that could
start a fire wildfire spread
could be tremendous with those gusty
winds tomorrow 86 today a little bit
warmer
and then we'll stay in the mid 80s
tomorrow but getting windy clouds sunday
hold temps back a little
there's that chance of showers it's
about 30 to 40 percent
i think the greater amounts will be up
into lincoln and over into mojave
counties but i think clark county is
going to get some rain
on monday slight chance on tuesday and
then it's gone sunshine and warmth we're
jumping into the 90's by thursday